Queridos amigos, amigas,
hasta Donald Trump lo dijo,
Boris Johnson ha sido tachado en numerosas
ocasiones de ser algo así como el Trump de
la política británica. Y no se trata
solo de una comparación estética,
ni de que ambos líderes generen constantemente
un montón de contenido para la prensa rosa.
Porque sí, sabemos que la vida privada de estos
dos personajes es de todo menos discreta. Ambos
se encuentran en su tercer matrimonio y los dos
llegaron al poder teniendo 5 hijos - que se sepa.
La diferencia es que Boris Johnson, entre
fiesta y fiesta, ha tenido otros dos vástagos
en su tiempo como premier. Pero es que
acaso ¿hay mejor fórmula para combatir
el envejecimiento de la población británica
que un baby boom en el 10 de Downing Street?
Sea como sea, la caída de Johnson ha sido
particularmente llamativa teniendo en cuenta
que apenas dos años y medio antes este Primer
Ministro británico fue capaz de cosechar un
rotundo éxito electoral, la mayoría conservadora
más grande desde los tiempos de Margaret Thatcher.
Una caída sorprendente para un líder que en
septiembre del 2021 se imaginaba a sí mismo
como el Primer Ministro británico de la época
moderna que más tiempo permanecería en el cargo.
(Boris Johnson contempla otra década en el poder)
Apenas unos meses antes de verse forzado
a dimitir, Johnson aspiraba a superar los
11 años de Margaret Thatcher en el poder. Al
final se ha quedado en 3 años y un poquito más.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Cómo se hizo
con los mandos de Downing Street un
tipo tan peculiar como Johnson?
¿Qué balance podemos hacer de su
etapa como Primer Ministro? ¿Qué ha sido
realmente lo que ha propiciado su caída?
En este vídeo vamos a responder estas preguntas,
pero antes, antes tenemos que empezar por el
principio. Tenemos que ver un poco de historia.
T1(¿A QUIÉN LE IMPORTA LA VERDAD?)
Que Boris Johnson mintiera al Parlamento sobre su
asistencia durante el confinamiento a las fiestas
celebradas en Downing Street no pilló por sorpresa
a los que siguen de cerca la política británica.
La trayectoria de Johnson está plagada de
momentos en los que se peleó con la verdad.
De hecho, la falta de compromiso con la verdad
es, quizás, una de las grandes manchas de este
político. ¿Pensáis que estoy exagerando?
Pues no… A lo largo de la trayectoria
profesional y política de Johnson esta
mancha ha estado siempre muy presente.
Pero empecemos por el principio. Tras estudiar en
el prestigioso Eton College y luego licenciarse
en Filología Clásica en la Universidad
de Oxford, Johnson comenzó su carrera
profesional como periodista en el Times, medio
del que fue despedido por inventarse una cita.
Tras este altercado, fue rescatado por el
Daily Telegraph, donde escribió columnas
que le empezaron a conectar con el electorado
conservador. Y a principios de los 90 fue
destinado como corresponsal a Bruselas,
donde comenzó a ganar fama por sus
duras posiciones euro-escépticas.
(Eso sí, esto fue algo que Johnson hizo a lo
grande: estuviera o no cargado de razones,
su estilo recurrió siempre a la exageración con
el objetivo de ridiculizar las instituciones
comunitarias. En sus textos Johnson llegó a decir
cosas como que la Comisión Europea quería prohibir
los cócteles de gambas y las salchichas británicas
o, incluso, que buscaba estandarizar el tamaño de
los profilácticos porque los italianos
tenían órganos sexuales más pequeños.)
De regreso al Reino Unido continuó trabajando
como columnista y se presentó, sin éxito,
a las elecciones a la Cámara de los
Comunes. Pero poco a poco gracias a
su trabajo y sobre todo a sus continuas
apariciones en el programa “Have I Got
News for You” de la BBC comenzó
a ser una figura muy conocida.
Le ofrecieron entonces convertirse en director de
The Spectator, una revista semanal sobre política,
cultura y asuntos internacionales. Eso sí,
la condición es que no se presentara como
diputado. Lo que Johnson pactó y, por
supuesto, dos años después incumplió.
Como político se ganó la confianza del
entonces líder conservador, Michael Howard,
si bien al poco tiempo este le apartó después
de que los medios dejaran en evidencia las
mentiras del bueno de Boris por un lío
de faldas, otra de sus grandes pasiones.
(Sea como sea, el caso es que en
2008 Boris Johnson se convirtió en
alcalde de Londres. Durante su mandato se
pusieron en marcha las obras del Crossrail,
un ambicioso tren de cercanías del
que ya os hablamos en Megaprojekts.
Y lo cierto es que su desempeño como alcalde le
cosechó una gran popularidad. Lo que le permitió
hacerse con la reelección. Una popularidad que
alcanzó el conjunto del país y también la escena
internacional gracias a ser el anfitrión
de los Juegos Olímpicos del año 2012.)
En semejante contexto y gozando de unos altísimos
niveles de aprobación hizo lo que 1.000 veces
había dicho que no haría: presentarse como
candidato a las parlamentarias del 2015.
Y así, desde la Cámara de los Comunes
se convirtió en una de las figuras
más destacadas en reclamar la salida
del Reino Unido de la Unión Europea,
teniendo un papel particularmente
estelar en el referéndum de 2016.
Por aquel entonces el Partido Conservador
llevaba 6 años en el poder con David Cameron
como primer ministro. Aquel referéndum se convocó
por muchos motivos pero esto que veis en pantalla
fue uno de los argumentos principales.
Y es que, veréis, tras la Gran Recesión,
muchos políticos, economistas y expertos
británicos que eran escépticos con la Unión
Europea defendieron que la culpa de la pobre
evolución de la economía británica tenía,
precisamente, mucho que ver con el
lastre que suponía el club europeo.
Johnson, que se movía como pez en el agua
en este terreno, fue desde el principio uno
de los grandes altavoces de esta campaña….
Campaña que, no hace falta que os recuerde,
fue todo un éxito y que terminó con
la propia dimisión de David Cameron.
Sustituido por Theresa May para
hacer cumplir el Brexit, Johnson,
como representante del ala más
dura de los partidarios del Brexit,
fue nombrado Ministro de Asuntos Exteriores y
permaneció en el cargo durante los dos primeros
años de los 3 que duró este gobierno.
Un gobierno que fue…. Un fracaso.
Theresa May, que no creía en el
Brexit, no consiguió prácticamente
avanzar nada. Y así entre dudas sobre
si el Brexit sería realmente posible,
le llegó la oportunidad a nuestro
protagonista de este vídeo:
el día 24 de julio del 2019, Boris Johnson se
convirtió en el Primer Ministro del Reino Unido.
De repente el discurso cambió
por completo y 5 meses después,
en las elecciones del 12 de diciembre Boris
Johnson aplastó a todos sus rivales. El Reino
Unido tenía un nuevo emperador…
Al menos en términos políticos.
(La campaña electoral de Boris Johnson en 2019 fue
muy clara, pidió el voto para conseguir 2 cosas:
llevar a cabo el Brexit sin mirar atrás
e impedir que Jeremy Corbyn, el por aquel
entonces escorado muy a la izquierda líder
laborista se hiciera con el gobierno británico.
Fue todo un éxito: A los clásicos feudos
conservadores se sumaron muchos distritos
de tradición laborista que habían
apostado por el Brexit y que no
se sentían particularmente entusiasmados por
el populismo de izquierdas de su candidato.)
Y, amigos, amigas, se podrán decir muchas cosas,
pero en esta ocasión Borish
Johnson cumplió su palabra:
Tras su aplastante derrota Corbyn
quedó fuera de la primera línea
política y cuando parecía imposible, el
Primer Ministro británico logró cerrar un
acuerdo con la Unión Europea para que el Brexit
se completara del todo el 31 de enero del 2020.
Es verdad, que el acuerdo no fue precisamente
el deseado por los hooligans de un Brexit duro,
puesto que Irlanda del Norte continúa
perteneciendo al mercado único europeo
de mercancías… Algo que desde entonces ha
sido un enorme quebradero de cabeza y una
inagotable fuente de conflictos políticos.
¿Por qué? Pues porque pertenecer al mercado
europeo de mercancías conlleva no formar
parte del propio mercado británico.
Esta frontera comercial en el mar de Irlanda
incomoda a muchos en Gran Bretaña e incluso
el propio Johnson amenazó con frecuencia
con romper el llamado Protocolo de Irlanda.
Y eso no es todo: el Brexit es una oportunidad
pero también un riesgo. Que salga mejor o peor
en el medio y largo plazo dependerá esencialmente
de las políticas que adopte el gobierno británico.
Esto parece de cajón, ¿Verdad? El problema es que
se vendió otra cosa. Muchos líderes pro-Brexit,
incluido el propio Johnson, pintaron
que todo sería un camino de rosas.
Que la mera salida de la Unión Europea
supondría algo así como meter el turbo
economía y que de repente todos
serían más ricos y más prósperos.
Pero la realidad es la contraria…. A corto
plazo el Brexit supone mucha incertidumbre
y la necesidad de llevar a cabo un sin fin de
ajustes que ralentizan la economía. Por ejemplo,
según datos del Centro para la Reforma Europea,
hasta ahora el Brexit ha supuesto para el Reino
Unido una caída en la inversión y el comercio
del 10% frente a un crecimiento mundial del 6%.
Sí, a medio y largo plazo puede ser una
gran oportunidad pero eso requerirá tiempo,
paciencia y sobre todo políticas que
mejoren la competitividad británica. Y aquí,
Johnson tampoco ha estado particularmente
a la altura. Ha presentado muchos grandes
planes interesantes, pero a la hora de la verdad
se ha ejecutado y avanzado muy poco. Y, en cambio,
lo que sí ha hecho ha sido gastar a manos llenas
e incrementar los impuestos a las empresas. Y eso,
eso es algo que también ha contribuido a erosionar
su peso dentro del movimiento conservador.
Pero no solo podemos hablar del Brexit y
sus consecuencias. La era de Johnson nos
deja muchas más historias. Atentos.
(LAS MEDIAS VERDADES COMO POLÍTICA)
Amigos, amigas, la política exterior ha sido,
con mucha diferencia, el ámbito en el que más
se notan los cambios provocados por el Brexit.
Mientras la maquinaria europea acostumbra a
ser lenta y pesada, Londres ha ganado mucha
agilidad a la hora de fijar su posición en
los grandes temas de la escena internacional.
Lo que ha hecho que el propio Boris Johnson
sea ahora mismo más querido en el extranjero
que en su propio país. Mirad, por ejemplo,
quién fue el que más se alegró de que Johnson
superara en junio una moción de censura.
Efectivamente, el Reino Unido está apoyando
a Ucrania sin fisuras. De hecho, en Ucrania
están tan agradecidos con Boris Johnson que
le han dedicado una calle en la ciudad de
Odessa. Y seguramente no sea la última.
Luego, el acuerdo AUKUS entre Australia,
Estados Unidos y el Reino Unido supuso otra gran
victoria diplomática, algo así como: “Londres está
de vuelta en la escena internacional”.
Pero las buenas noticias se
terminan prácticamente aquí.
Y es que veréis, otro ámbito en el que
al final consiguió un destacado liderazgo fue en
la gestión de la pandemia. El gobierno británico
apostó firmemente por las vacunas y logró tasas de
vacunación similares a las que consiguió Israel en
las primeras etapas del proceso de vacunación.
Algo que también hizo que los partidarios del
Brexit sacaran pecho con gráficos como este:
Claro que no todo le salió tan bien.
A nivel nacional, su política estrella
fue la conocida como “Levelling up”,
algo así como subir y equilibrar. Su objetivo
pasaba por lograr un mayor desarrollo económico
en las midlands de Inglaterra, en Gales, en
Irlanda del Norte y en Escocia. Es decir, en todas
aquellas partes del país que no han logrado tantos
éxitos como el área metropolitana de Londres y las
grandes ciudades inglesas. La idea era incrementar
mucho la inversión pública en estos territorios.
(Durante décadas el Gobierno de Reino Unido ha
hablado de reducir las desigualdades entre el
dinamismo de Londres y el sur de Inglaterra
con el resto de territorios. Al respecto se
ha hablado mucho, pero se ha hecho más
bien poco y con escaso éxito. La City
sigue concentrándolo todo. Y todo indica
que así seguirá siendo por el momento.)
Pues bien, apostar por el Levelling Up acarreaba
un aliciente añadido para Johnson. Su mayoría
absoluta supuso para los tories obtener
diputados en los lugares más insospechados.
Y esto ha generado dos grandes corrientes
en el Partido Conservador. A la clásica
corriente liberal de los tories de Londres y del
sureste, se ha unido otro movimiento, uno muy
conservador pero mucho más intervencionista:
el del norte y las Midlands que reclaman un
fuerte incremento del gasto público.
Y ahí es donde Johnson quería apostar
buena parte de su capital político, y para
ello el gobierno tenía que movilizar enormes
cantidades de inversión pública. El problema, por
supuesto, es que los recursos no son infinitos.
Los planes de estímulo para apoyar la recuperación
post-covid, junto a los costes de la propia
pandemia y del resto de planes del gobierno
han traído consigo algo que sería duramente
condenado por la propia Margaret Thatcher:
(Reino Unido se encuentra entre las
primeras naciones occidentales en aumentar los
impuestos para cubrir los costes del Covid-19)
Amigos, el sistema británico de salud no
pasa por su mejor momento. Las listas de
espera se multiplican y afectan a millones de
pacientes. Y como el crecimiento económico está
lejos del esperado y aún más lejos del
prometido durante la campaña del Brexit,
Boris Johnson buscó incrementar sus recursos
tirando de todo un clásico: subir los impuestos.
De esta forma incrementa la fiscalidad
sobre las nóminas de los trabajadores en
2,5 puntos a repartir a partes iguales
entre las empresas y sus empleados.
Además el impuesto de sociedades pasará del 19%
al 25% en abril de 2023. El encargado de impulsar
estas medidas fue Rishi Sunak, el Canciller de
Hacienda, que al parecer se oponía a financiar
las expansiones de gasto completamente con deuda.
Sea como sea, lo que está claro es que los planes
de estímulo pueden resultar más o menos populares,
pero subir los impuestos es algo que no le gusta a
casi nadie, sobre todo en el lado conservador.
Y mucho menos en un momento como este.
(La inflación de Reino Unido alcanza un nuevo
máximo en 40 años del 9,4% a medida que se
profundiza la crisis del coste de la vida)
Y luego está la crisis de la energía y las
cada vez más altas facturas que
reciben los hogares británicos.
Así que claro: las promesas
incumplidas, los desengaños,
la inflación y las subidas de impuestos
han terminado por erosionar y mucho el
capital político de Boris Johnson y sus
apoyos dentro del Partido Conservador.
Claro que su dimisión ha tenido mucho más que ver
con su comportamiento personal que con el
hasta ahora mediocre rendimiento logrado.
Atentos.
T3(
EL ENGAÑO COMO MÉTODO DE SUPERVIVENCIA)
A estas alturas tampoco merece la pena
entrar en muchos detalles respecto a todas
las idas y venidas de Boris Johnson con el
escándalo del “Partygate”. [Y por cierto, ¿podemos
dejar de poner la coletilla de “gate” a cualquier
escándalo? ¡Ni que el Watergate hubiera
sido un escándalo relacionado con el agua!]
El caso es que con el tema de la fiesta, intentó
engañar a los británicos, al Parlamento y a todo
el mundo. La realidad es que en mayo de 2020 un
montón de altos cargos del Gobierno se juntaban
en los jardines de Downing Street para tomar su
tradicional vino de los viernes mientras el resto
de los británicos tenía prohibido socializar y
hacer prácticamente cualquier cosa que no fuera
estar en casa y si acaso en el trabajo.
Así que podéis imaginaros la indignación
que provocaron noticias como esta:
(Boris Johnson esmultado por la policía
por incumplir el confinamiento con fiestas en
las instalaciones del gobierno de Reino Unido)
Ante esto Johnson llegó a decir que bueno,
que es que nadie le había avisado que
asistir a aquellos eventos incumplía las
normas de distanciamiento social aprobadas
por su propio Gobierno. Como podéis imaginar,
ante una tomadura de pelo tan evidente,
hubo muchos tories que empezaron a retirarle su
apoyo al primer ministro. Johnson puso en marcha
entonces la llamada Operation Red Meat, un intento
desesperado de recuperar el apoyo de los suyos.
(Esta Operación Carne Roja incluía políticas
tan disparatadas como entregar el control del
Canal de la Mancha a la Royal Navy, que no
cuenta con las embarcaciones adecuadas para
combatir la inmigración ilegal. También un
acuerdo para deportar a los sin papeles a
países africanos como Ruanda o Nigeria,
algo que hizo que el príncipe Carlos de
Inglaterra dejara a un lado su neutralidad
para calificar esta política como espantosa.)
Y así, Johnson fue perdiendo la confianza de
los tories hasta el punto de que a principios
de junio de 2022 le presentaron una moción de
censura. Johnson consiguió superar la moción
pero su Gobierno quedó herido de muerte.
Y la puntilla al primer ministro la dio el
escándalo Pincher. Chris Pincher era un alto
cargo del grupo parlamentario del Partido
Conservador que dimitió a finales de junio al
ser acusado de agredir sexualmente a dos hombres.
El escándalo estalló al saberse que Pincher
había sido nombrado para esta responsabilidad
por Boris Johnson a pesar de que éste ya conocía
que arrastraba acusaciones similares de la etapa
de ambos en el Ministerio de Asuntos Exteriores.
El escándalo Pincher provocó la dimisión inmediata
del canciller de Hacienda, Rishi Sunak, y
también del ministro de Sanidad, Sajid Javid,
que fue muy elocuente ante el Parlamento para
definir la deriva que estaba tomando Johnson.
La dimisión de estos 2 ministros fue
el principio del fin. En apenas 36
horas renunciaron a sus responsabilidades
hasta 50 altos cargos del Gobierno. Y ese,
ese fue el final, al menos
por ahora, de Boris Johnson.
Y digo por ahora porque ya hay rumores de que
el líder británico se ha propuesto volver a
la primera fila para recuperar
el trono que le han arrebatado.
Sea como sea, su despedida en el Parlamento
británico no dejó indiferente a nadie:
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para todos
vosotros: ¿Qué recuerdo dejará en tu memoria
Boris Johnson? ¿Qué consejo le darías al futuro
primer ministro británico? Déjanos tu respuesta en
los comentarios. Como siempre, si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo no olvides darle a like y
compartirlo con tus amigos. No olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.